joining us is Rob stone who you can
follow on Twitter at Rob stone on Fox
Rob Darren Smith in for Rich Eisen thank
you very much
yeah happy to do it throwing it with my
family in Paris here not standing on one
of I think 8000 bridges over the river
son just for you guys well thank you and
we appreciate that you were behind the
last time we chatted I believe it was
last summer and you were also on an off
day but you were not with family you
were with Alexi Lalas and I believe
there may or may not have been some
vodka involved yeah yeah it was and
usually I am I am with him he's my he's
my partner on the road in crime at these
World Cups but I'd love to hear that you
guys you know if it got so invested into
this tournament it's one of those
entities one of those problems that
that's really nice but as of late and
yeah we use Americans so remember that
guy and with a state was able to do it
it has to go in and the coal nation at
the Rose Bowl bit the gospel is really
spreading now you know and it's it's
spreading across Europe and 78 corn
finalists are European countries and
that's because these countries have
decided to to invest time money
resources coaching into becoming better
soft nation that it and it's paying off
and there's there's definitely a concern
that not only is the gap closing with
the US Women's National Team but that
they could be getting a last year at
some point and I mean that in a good way
because that's that's just going to make
this game stronger and better but the
development in these other countries and
what they've done infrastructure wise is
starting to rival on top what the US has
right and Rob I'm just a casual viewer
I'm not an expert in any capacity but
even going back to 2015 it does seem
like the quality is better you know you
talked about some of the infrastructure
in some of these other countries and I
think it's important to point out like
these are soccer crazy countries you
know so whereas we had perceived
monopoly on the women's game you know at
least our attitude towards women's
soccer was we had a perceive monopoly
here it's sort of starting to feel like
countries Spain Germany France which
we'll talk about here in a second it
feels like they've got an amazing
opportunity those objects in the mirror
a lot closer than they appear 108 you
can throw Italy into that conversation
as well as they were able to move on to
the round of 8 so it is spreading and
it's interesting how it spreads in
different places you know the us set up
is unique because it's the women have
had a success
right from the outset so so many people
associate American soccer with the
success of this US Women's National Team
where if you're talking Italy or you're
talking Spain or the Netherlands and
clearly around the men's program what
they do it
European Championships are what they do
at the World Cup so there's been this
inherent bias against the women's game
because the men had done so well and
this is what they are programmed to
watch and see and expect and accept but
now some of these nations have hit a
speed bump
you know if you talk about Italy in the
Netherlands their national teams have
had some struggles not at the World Cup
like the u.s. last summer and they're
kind of turning their attention turning
their focus and their energy to the
women's game and the fans are coming out
and they're getting these results and
people are saying well it's not just
this men's game that is fascinating and
captivating it's the women's game as
well and it is faster it is quicker it
is electric it is infinitely more
entertaining to watch than it was 15 20
years ago our Direct TV 4k World Cup
report Rob stone from Fox Sports joining
us from Paris here this is the Rich
Eisen show I'm Darren Smith in for Rich
Eisen var replay it's a subject in every
sport in soccer they refer to it as far
the video assistant referee robbed it
last summer again dating back to the
men's world cup everybody fretted about
it there was a lot of hand-wringing and
it seemed to work it worked really
really well and it got great grades
across the board yet for whatever reason
does it feel different in this
tournament here has it's been a subject
that you guys have talked a lot about on
that great set as I mentioned but does
it feel like it's working as well as we
all said it did during the Men's World
Cup last year yeah it's good I
understand why there's that perception
out there where people are saying this
is not working and confusing and what it
is there's a couple factors at play
number one I fab which is the governing
we bought
the lawmakers of the game came down with
their new rules if you will and they
came down to June just before this
Women's World Cup started so essentially
everybody's kind of coping and dealing
with some new rules and do way things
were being interpreted and one of them
and the biggest one is that var is being
used as that eye in the sky on those
pelvic acts which was never the case and
it it's interesting because the new
rules came in and they mastic basically
made it easier for the goalies instead
of to see happen you know the line at
the time of the kick they're saying
guess what guys we're cutting you a
break it just needs to be one foot ok
these are the rules and they've always
been the rules the problem is for
decades and decades and generations
people haven't broken that rule and they
just kind of got away with it you know
there's that great snapshot of Brianna
scurry bouncing off from line to deny
Chyna a penalty kick attempt at the 99
World Cup she was put now to also up
like an incredible amount that today
would be a no-brainer you get called but
what whereas there's this disconnect is
that so many of these women have never
played with var and then there's the new
rule and people are saying wait a second
why is that being denied she's just a
you know two inches off the line guess
what it's still wrong it's still
cheating it's still against the rules we
didn't make the rules
we just are actually now governing that
rule so I think there's that big
disconnect and why so many people were
making such noise about it but guess
what they've adapted already and in the
last six days there's been hardly any
chatter about it we've had some really
tight offside calls which have obviously
said stop a firestorm of emotions in a
lot of places for the most part I think
the rate is like 99 point something
percent that they are getting things
correct and right so var is working and
you may not like it right now but you
will adapt you will grow to understand
it and appreciate it and everybody will
as well including the players and there
was a great disconnect for a lot of
these players from certain nations about
what the rules actually were and when
they sit down and they reread the laws
and they're re reminded what how they
should be playing under these
circumstances they'll realize that that
they were wrong and the eye in the sky
var got it right and whether we're
talking
about international soccer here or
something that's been discussed on this
show with instant replay in the NFL and
Rob you obviously work in college
football we're not going backwards we're
not going in Reverse when it comes to
technology and video replay so it's up
to the players and the coaches and
everybody else to adjust to it even if
there might be a better way to do it the
quarterfinals Rob start tomorrow Norway
versus England that'll be three o'clock
on Fox and then Friday France versus the
United States something else I've heard
mentioned on this show this this feels
kind of like a final I'm sure there's a
simple explanation maybe it's speaker
rankings how did France United
states.the to betting favorites heading
into the tournament House is a
quarterfinal dumb luck played a simple
dumb luck countries are drawn and
they're placed in a group there's no
kind of hey we're gonna hide you from
them until the last possible moment it
just doesn't work that way so if you're
a seeded team like the u.s. was like
France was you were put in your own
little pot and you're on the top of your
group and then you are paired with quote
unquote lesser teams to fill out your
group from that point it's just kind of
the stage of where you go a the group
winners look at some point in a big
tournament you're going to run into a
heavyweight right it's just that this
one seems it seems at a minimum one
match too early I think if this was a
semi-final people would say I did it all
right a quarterfinal you do wish and and
you don't want to encourage FIFA to play
too much and kind of bend things they
have a history of some shenanigans right
right there is that that feeling here
and certainly in America that point is
this would be great if it was the final
or if it was a semi final but in the end
if you'll be a fantastic setting you
know a sold-out parc des Plantes one of
these historic venues here in paris you
know the u.s. men played here at the
World Cup in Nam in 98 the women had a
game here and I just came from Charles
de Gaulle Airport and let me tell you
the American invasion I was already
taking place it is game on right now in
Paris and and I really honestly believe
this I don't think France is going to
feel like they're the home team Friday
2:00 Eastern on Fox I think at a minimum
they're gonna say it's 50/50 and it
wouldn't surprise me in the least if
there's more American fans there
than French Wow interesting especially
in the host nation as well Rob stone
from Fox pours joining us the Direct TV
4k world cup report on the Rich Eisen
show I'm Darren Smith so are you holding
tickets I we've read about $11,000
$6,000 $5,000 if you walk around in
Paris as you were doing right now do you
know that there's a World Cup
quarter-final coming up I mean and you
mentioned Charles de Gaulle airplane the
ticket pricing is just no yeah that's
one of the that's one of the frustrating
parts about this world cup and and we've
heard so are similar stories for those
of our colleagues you've traveled around
the country is that you're here like my
wife is like work is there with me right
now where we're walking right by the
Eiffel Tower II have no clue that a
World Cup is going on right now there's
no sign that there's no soccer balls in
the windows and jerseys and this and
that it's just it just happens to be
here and that's a shame and FIFA and
local organization committee they need
to change that but you would not know
that when you get to the stadium and
particularly when you get there Friday
and yes I bought five tickets to this
game because it was one of those
convenience games and I think that's why
there's maybe so many American fans
there school was out I want to go watch
the World Cup
who knows where who's going to play
right because you're just if the US came
in second they'd be on the other side of
the bracket maybe in other places so a
lot of people I think chose Paris as
their starting point and this was a game
that they could come to and they could
watch a game in Paris and it was super
convenient that's why I think you're
gonna see this tremendous influx of
American fans at this one
we heard the two goals from Megan
Rapinoe the two penalty kicks against
Spain in the previous round on Monday
Megan Rapinoe and I quote and I won't
give the full quote out here because
this is a family show as I've been told
to expect an S show circus we're all
know what s show circus means I think
Rob what is an S show circus and is that
what you're expecting on Friday in Paris
I am I am except expecting that and and
what that is is it's going to be a
portrait really to be honest with you of
how the women's game is viewed and
portrayed and accepted and embraced you
are going to see thousands and thousands
of fans and not just in the stadium but
outside as well you're going to see
parties you're going to see marches by
the American outlaws it's a proper
soccer environment it is exactly what we
would expect for a men's quarterfinal
game and you're gonna see it on the
women's side it is going to be a show it
is going to be a circus but it's going
to be the greatest three-ring circus
you've ever seen and that the u.s. moves
on a lot of people say this is as you
guys said the final get through this
game and the other two should be a
breeze I don't buy that it's not quite
Miracle on Ice you know where you took
places you took care of Russia earlier
yeah you still had one more to go
but this will be as big of a of a scene
on involving women's soccer I think
since the 1999 final at the Rose Bowl
championship or bust it has to be for
this u.s. national team you know they're
there Duke and basketball they're you
know they're Alabama and college
football right now that you enter a
tournament in near the u.s. women's
national team you're there to win it so
anything less than at a minimum a
championship game appearance is a
failure Rob we appreciate it thank you
so much coverage begins two o'clock
Eastern watching you got it of course
we're all invested here on this radio on
this program on the Rich Eisen show
thank you to rob stone for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app